One of the economic and cultural changes
that we've seen pretty dramatically in
the last few decades is the sheriff,
lung,
young adults who never leave home even
after they go through their schooling or
at some point in their young lives,
boomerang back home.
And we estimate that more than 40%,
nearly half of all millennials have
either never,
never left,
never launched,
if you will or at some point have
boomeranged back home.
You know,
he can't find a job if you're,
if you're underemployed,
if you're at a non nonpaying internship,
all those sorts of journeys,
a mom and dad's home,
it ain't bad place to hang out.
You know,
the refrigerator is usually stocked and
you don't have to put coins in the
laundry.
And interestingly,
um,
I think there was,
in my generation,
there was some stigma attached to that,
uh,
you know,
get on with your life already ready for
goodness sake.
You know,
we've done some surveying of both the
parents have such young adults and young
adults themselves looking for tension
within those homes,
looking for conflict,
looking for stigma.
And frankly,
we don't find that much in part because
it has,
it has become more commonplace and
people sort of understand.
Yeah,
that's,
uh,
that's the nature of the slow passage
into adulthood.
Uh,
you know,
there are societies in the world and,
and a southern Europe,
particularly Italy come to mind where
culturally young men have been living
with their mothers,
uh,
you know,
in into their thirties and forties.
A bum bocce on is big baby and mommy smo
his mamma's boy.
And some of this is cultural,
uh,
as some of this is clearly economic and,
and Europe frankly has the same
challenges with not enough jobs for
young adults that we have.
So a lot of the world is,
is,
is going through this.
I think the silver lining is a,
that there don't seem to be a lot of
stresses.
Again,
I speak as a baby boomer who came of age
in the sixties and there was a whiff of
generation war in the air.
It was a time when there was a,
uh,
you know,
there's a women's rights movement,
civil rights movement,
anti war protests.
There was a feeling that the older
generation had screwed everything up and
thank God w here we were to make
everything right.
There was almost a sort of a finger of
accusation pointed at the older
generation.
You see virtually none of that,
uh,
with uh,
within the younger generation.
In some ways I have a sense from our
surveys,
uh,
that young adults have sort of
seamlessly migrated from being the
children to their parents in many cases
to being the roommates or their parents
and they have the similar interests and
they text each other and they get on
with their lives and there's a certain
sort of resilience there.
That's a snapshot of a moment,
you know,
in this slower passage to adulthood.
I again,
I don't think we yet know fast
forwarding a a decade or two down the
road,
uh,
what that will mean,
what that will mean for the family
formations of these young adults.
I suspect what it does mean is that the
intergenerational interdependence that
we see in these families is likely to
last a,
there is no question that families stay
closer to each other father into the
life.
Then may have been the case in the past.
And when we talk about generational
personalities,
let's acknowledge upfront we are deep
into the realm of generalization and
stereotype and there within any
generation,
there as many differences between
individuals as there are across
generations.
And the idea that if you're born in one
year,
you're a member of one generation and
therefore have one part of a
personality,
but you were born a year later,
you're or another generation that flies
in the face of common sense,
obviously.
Have you said that you can look at broad
patterns and we can see this with our
attitudinal data,
our voting behavior or economic
circumstances.
And again,
accepting,
accepting the caveat that these are big
generalizations.
Um,
there are,
there are a number of things that do
stand out in terms of the person persona
of this generation.
One of them is awareness.
Um,
there was a classic question in social
science,
uh,
about what we call social trust.
And the question goes very simply,
generally speaking,
would you say most people can be trusted
or you can't be too careful when you're
dealing with other people?
Uh,
we,
the Pew Research Center and other
research organizations have been asking
this question for 40 years and we've
never seen a generation that is as low
on social trust as millennials are.
So only about 19% of millennials,
the last time we asked this question
say,
yeah,
most people can be trusted.
Uh,
it's a very interesting finding because
millennials are also a play nicely with
other,
uh,
a generation.
And I think,
you know,
we all got that report card in
kindergarten plays nicely with others.
I think millennials must have all done
very well on that.
How do you square these two seemingly
opposite characteristics?
I'm not,
frankly,
I'm not sure I can,
but let me,
let me put forward a couple of
interesting theories to start with.
The social trust finding.
One of the things that a sociologist no
and psychologists have observed is that
a population groups within a population,
uh,
that feel vulnerable for whatever
reason,
tend to be low on social trust because
they're not well fortified to deal with
the consequences of misplaced trust.
So if you think about the millennial
generation and you think about their
demographic characteristics,
uh,
a large share are nonwhite and a large
share at the lower end of the
socioeconomic scale.
In both cases,
you know,
that places them or may place them in a,
in a,
in an attitude of vulnerability.
Uh,
and therefore you can't be too careful.
I think it's possible that the fact that
they navigate,
they do so much of their social
interaction online may lead to
awareness.
Uh,
it's one thing to have a face to face
friends and those sorts of relationships
where you can,
you have a history of people,
you can read body language,
you can do all the things that friends
tend to do when you have relationships
that are entirely mediated through an,
through an online setting.
Uh,
it's more complicated and I think people
come around the view they'd not
everybody's exactly who they say they
are.
Uh,
online.
a final possibility is the way then the
very nurturing parenting norms,
uh,
that raised millennials.
Millennials came of age in the nineties
and arts,
uh,
in an era of global terrorism,
of domestic school shootings.
Columbine,
nine 11,
not a pretty horrible things that are
particularly disturbing to parents.
Uh,
the worry about strangers online,
online predators and all the rest.
Social psychologists would say that they
have been raised in a very protective
nurturing environment.
It is a kind of an,
everybody gets a trophy quality to the
way millennials have been raised.
Your precious,
it's a mean and difficult world.
I need to protect you,
which may then be picked up by,
by the children raised this way.
As you better be careful,
you better be wary.
Uh,
again,
I,
I wouldn't push this too far,
but,
but one real world consequence that is
already observable among the millennials
is in their economic behaviors.
They appeared to be a risk averse
generation.
Now maybe that's because they don't,
they don't have money.
They don't have the economic security
that leads to a freedom to take risks.
Uh,
or maybe,
maybe it's the way they've been raised,
but w w w one of the data points is a,
you know,
fidelity and other companies that manage
401k's,
uh,
and kind of have a sense of the
investment ha habits and patterns of
millions and millions of people who
work,
have noticed in the last five or six
years that the young adults in these,
in these 401k programs,
when they look at their investment
choices,
uh,
and,
you know,
the,
the advice to the young adults is the,
a little bit you,
you know,
you're young,
you have time,
be aggressive,
you know,
a stock portfolio over the long haul of
supposed to do better,
et Cetera,
et Cetera.
Uh,
many young adults are not taking that
advice.
I think you can see that in their
consumption habits as well.
Again,
either because they don't have the money
or they don't want to take on the debt.
Uh,
they're not buying cars.
They're,
I find houses.
Um,
and I think there is a kind of wariness
that cuts across a lot of dimensions of
their lives.